What strikes me,
if you will,
but this is not the particular case of the president of the
Republic,
this is the case for the whole political class
today,
This is the case for all journalists,
is that you don't know anything about armies,
you do not know the heart of the armies,
you don't know by your fibers,
what armies are.
Neither does the president,
by definition.
President by definition.
No more than anyone of his generation
was
which is,
The long steps,
the nights of trouble,
the difficulty,
the pain.
It's not just military
or 1 civilian who has been given 1 uniform,
1 army is something very special,
with 1 own culture
which is 1 culture of commitment,
which is 1 culture of self-gift,
which is 1 culture of brotherhood of art,
which is 1 culture of the discipline,
we could come back,
but from a discipline
which comes from,
a very singular exercise of authority
within the military.